there are two things that I would love
to share about places in Colorado
actually the highest looping roller
coaster in the United States actually
resides in Colorado is its Defiance it's
a top of Iron Mountain and has 110t drop
and when you see this thing it's like
not only an incredible roller coaster it
gives you the ride of your life it's in
the middle of this kind of terrain it's
like a roller coaster out in nature
you can only visit the park by taking a
Scenic gondola ride and then also I
always go to a museum wherever I go and
the Denver Art Museum has an impeccable
collection a beautiful architectural
building and it's like super amazing
it's one of the largest museums between
Chicago and the West Coast with global
art collections more than 70,000 Works
in all 12 collections so if you are into
I don't know roller coasters there you
go if you're into art there you go
[Music]